Hey! Thanks for joining me, everyone.
Today, I'd like to start outlining the best way to merge our two engineering teams.
You know, we both follow Agile.
We use Jira but everybody uses Agile just a little differently.
Now, Karen, I've taken a look at your active sprint and it seems super organized.
It's really impressive.
Would you mind taking a moment to tell us about your sprint planning...
...and a little bit more about your Agile process.
Oh, sure.
Of course.
Let me start with my philosophy on Agile.
I really try to be customer-focused and make sure every sprint...
...is packed with stories based on real user feedback.
Our starting point...